Good day, everyone.
This is Jack Vanhorne from the University
of Southern California.
And I'd like to welcome you
all to The Big Data and Knowledge Guide to
the Fundamentals of Data Science.
Today, march 30th 2018, we are
delighted to have Dr. Curtis Huttenhower from
Harvard University's Chan School of Public
Health to discuss
Molecular Data and the Microbiome.
Dr. Huttenhower is an associate professor
of Computational Biology and Bioinformatics
at Harvard's Chan School
of Public Health.
And he's an associate member at the Broad
Institute.
He was an analysis lead on the NIH's
Human Microbiome Project.
And he currently leads the Human Microbiome
Bioactives Resource, where his lab
focuses on computational methods for functional
analysis of microbiome communities and the
micro-- and
microbiome epidemiology.
We're absolutely delighted to have him presenting
his work today, again, on the topic of molecular
data and the
microbiome.
During his presentation, I encourage our audience
members to submit any questions that you may
have for Dr. Huttenhower by using question
submission facility as part of the go to webinar
little panel usually it on
the right hand side of your screen.
And without further ado, I'd like to turn
this over to Dr. Huttenhower to begin his
presentation.
Thank you so much, Curtis, for presenting
today.
Excellent.
Likewise.
Thanks, Jack, everyone who organizes and everyone
who is attending.
I'm very pleased that
the technology can bring such a great group
of people together.
Hopefully I'm audible at this point?
You are.
Excellent.
OK, well, with that, as Jack said in that
very kind introduction, the group here works
on microbial
community and human microbiome studies with
a computational focus.
And this, of course, addresses questions
of how the collection of microbes we carry
in and on our bodies-- bacteria, fungi, viruses,
other types of microbes-
- affect our health outcomes.
So I'll to speak today both about some of
the ways in which this affects public health,
and of the accompanying computation and data
science challenges.
And it's easy to forget after the past few
years worth of interest in the microbiome
that it's actually been studied for
quite a long time.
Some of the earliest microscopy done by the
[INAUDIBLE] actually resulted in imaging of
his
own human microbiome, of microbes isolated
from his oral microbial community.
as somebody who sits at a
school of public health, though perhaps some
of the more urgent reason to study the microbiome
is the rise in
chronic non pathogenic but immunal linked
disease over the past several decades.
So collections of diseases like type 1 diabetes
or inflammatory bowel disease-- which I'll
speak about today-- that
are affected by our immune system's interaction
with our typical microbial environment, but
which are not caused
by a specific pathogen, like an infectious
disease.
And the microbiome has now been linked to
a really surprising
range of chronic disease.
Not just gut centered conditions, like inflammatory
bowel disease, but systemic ones like
type 1 diabetes, rheumatoid arthritis, or
even behavioral conditions like autism.
And it's easy to imagine over the past, say
75 years, the range of environmental exposures
that have changed
how we-- that have changed the interaction
between our immune system and our microbes
that we evolved with
for millions of preceding years.
It includes some obvious things like diet
or the environment that surrounds us,
where we live and work, antimicrobial exposures
that have evolved a great deal since the 1950s.
But then also
some less obvious ones, like certainly probiotics,
other pharmaceutical exposures, but even how
we're born, how
we age, or things like our daily stress levels
that can modify how our immune system interacts
with our natural
microbes.
So the microbiome provides a high dimensional
readout of human health and of molecular activity
in much the
same way that, say, human genetics or human
gene expression can.
This can be used to do things like predict
disease risk or disease prognosis.
But unlike these other readouts, the microbiome
has the potential to be
modified.
So certainly antibiotics are a huge modification,
and there is interest in other types of more
targeted
modifications of the microbiome to not just
read out but restore health, once we figure
out the right ways in which
to do it.
So that's one of the main goals of our research.
And one of the main tools that's used by us
and the entire
microbiome research community is high throughput
sequencing.
And, again, this is really aided the past
several
years renaissance in microbial community studies.
To give a quick overview of how sequencing
is used as one of the molecular tools for
microbial community
studies, any such study-- be it the human
microbiome or otherwise-- starts with typically
a culture independent
sample of microbes, and laces the cells--
breaks them open-- to extract nucleotides,
DNA, or increasingly RNA to
understand microbial transcription as well
as microbial genomes.
There are two common types of sequencing that
are used for microbial communities studies.
The first of which I'll refer to is amplicon
sequencing relies on PCR to amplify a single
marker gene from within this
entire pool of microbial DNA.
This is most commonly regions of the conserved
16S RNA gene.
So this is a gene
that's carried by essentially of all bacteria,
specifically.
And by amplifying only variants of that one
gene, each
variant-- each sequencing read-- can be used
to detect variants at that one position.
So a very cost effective and
efficient way to use sequencing to study microbial
communities.
Each read just looks at changes within this
one gene.
And those small changes can be classified
back to
reference databases that tell us where they
came from, which organism they came from.
So this gives us
essentially a microbial census in which each
sample generates a list of microbes and how
many reads were
classified to them.
So it counts how much or at what percentage
of each taxon-- each organism-- is detected
per
sample.
An alternative to amplicon-- or 16S sequencing
as it's called-- is metagenomic sequencing
of DNA, or meta
transcriptomic sequencing of RNA in which
you just plain sequence everything.
So very much like shotgun
sequencing of individual genomes-- like the
human genome-- this type of metagenomic or
metatranscriptomic
sequencing generates a pile of short reads.
But rather than being from a single organism,
they're derived from
tens or hundreds or sometimes thousands of
different organisms within a community.
So this can be used to get a more complete
picture of an underlying microbial community
at the cost of some
more computational and data science complexity.
The types of information you can then derive
from this includes
not just quantifying which bugs are there,
but figuring out what genes they might be
carrying, putting-- to some
degree-- those genes back together into microbial
genomes, figuring out what kinds of metabolism
or
biochemistry is contained within those genomes.
We're zooming way in and looking at microbial
genetics and very
precise variants within those microbial communities.
Again, kind of like you would for our human
genetic
population study.
So these two complementary types of sequencing
are some of the main tools used to generate
data about
microbial communities in the human microbiome.
And they're increasingly accompanied by a
collection of other
molecular data types that can be derived from
microbiome samples.
And when I say sample here, don't think too
hard about what that might be.
we'll get into the guts of the situation literally
in a few slides.
Between now and then though, in addition to
sequencing data, microbial communities can
be studied in a number
of ways, briefly summarized here as cellular
data.
So including things like direct visualization
through high
throughput microscopy, or sometimes culture
based methods-- actually growing organisms
from a sample, rather
than treating each culture independently--
or using cell sorting methods, such as flow
cytometry, that directly
counts which cells are there.
In addition to these cell focused methods,
other types of biomolecular data-- typically
derived from microbial
communities-- include mass spec results such
as metabolomic or proteomic quantification.
And these can then
accompany the two types of amplicon or methgenomes
and methatranscriptomes sequencing described
on the
previous slide.
The types of information that one can get
out of these sequencing data in particular
include things
like taxonomic profiling.
In other words figuring out which bugs are
there like we described for example sequencing.
Or there are ways to
In other words figuring out which bugs are
there like we described for example sequencing.
Or there are ways to
zoom in on specific variance within amplicon
to identify not just which organisms, but
which exact strain, which
exact type of each microbe is present in a
community.
These are both possible from amplicon sequencing,
which
again looks at just one gene, one locust or
one source of variation in a microbial community.
Methagenomes and
methatranscriptomes can generate additional
complementary data, such as functional profiling,
which again
quantifies the genes or pathways present in
a collection of communities.
Or in addition to taxonomic profiling and
variant haplotyping, like amplicon data can
generate, methagenomes can provide assemblies.
So either whole or
sometimes partial microbial genomes derive
directly from cultured independent communities.
And these genomes can also tell you about
which pods, biochemistry, or strain variation
are present.
So, finally,
from all of these different data types these
can be-- they can be carried downstream for
integration, different types
of statistics, or visualization.
And these include things like molecular epidemiology,
associating changes in the
microbiome with covariants-- health outcomes,
disease status, environmental exposures.
Further analyzes can be performed focusing
on molecular biology or biochemistry.
What pathways are microbes
using to generate small molecules that affect
our guts or our systemic health.
Computate-- or comparative
genomics or phylogenetics, so zooming in on
which strains are present.
How they evolve.
How things like
antibiotics might affect a microbial selection
in the entire microbiome.
Or, finally, things like systems biology or
biophysical models, looking at the dynamics
of community change using combinations of
these data.
So I'll touch on several of these different
data analysis types from multiple different
types of microbiome data
today, using mainly examples from the Human
Microbiome Project.
This will include both what is commonly
referred to as the Human Microbiome Project
or HMP now-- which I'll refer to as HMP1,
having wrapped up a few
years ago now.
So the HMP1 was an NAH funded project to define
a baseline of normal human microbial
variation.
Unlike our genomes-- which are 99.9% plus
similar from person to person, and the last
few variants obviously
matter quite a bit-- our microbiomes rarely
overlap by more than 10% from person to person.
There's a huge
amount of normal baseline variation in what
microbes we carry.
So several years ago now, the HMP1 set out
in a
quote, healthy or baseline population, to
define the bounds of this normal variation.
Or really to just understand
who's there, which microbes are present in
what configuration in the absence of perturbations
from disease.
So after wrapping up in 2012, the HMP1 provided
sort of a baseline catalog to contextualize
disease associated
variations in the microbiology.
Those were further study by the HMP2-- or
integrative HMP-- which is just recently
wrapping up.
And this has more of a functional mandate
from the NIH to analyze the biology, and specifically
functional molecular biology, of both the
microbiome and close interaction dynamically
over time, and with a focus
on disease in addition to this quote, healthy
baseline.
So the HMP2 consisted of three main projects
with three specific disease targets.
I'll speak today about our work
in inflammatory bowel disease.
And this project was accompanied by two other
than the HMP2 on pregnancy and
pre-term birth at Virginia Commonwealth, and
type 2 diabetes and obesity at Stanford and
Jackson labs.
As you'll see in several slides, all of these
project's data are available through our Data
Coordination Center run at
the University of Maryland.
So to speak a little bit to inflammatory bowel
disease as an environment in which to
study the microbiome, it's been a model for
different types of gut microbial dysbiosis
for a surprisingly long period
of time.
So even before the recent burst of work in
human microbiome studies, you can go back
many decades
and find language in publications that's surprisingly
modern, with respect to describing how the
gut microbiome is
perturbed in a complex way in inflammatory
bowel disease.
And so IBD became a model for microbiome studies
over the course, again, of several decades.
Starting in the
1940s and 1950s when the disease was observed
to be sometimes responsive to antibiotic treatment,
but without
a single isolatable or cultural pathogen that
seemed to be causative.
This continued over the subsequent few
decades, as other types of treatments were
introduced-- [INAUDIBLE] that are still common
treatments for
inflammatory bowel diseases, which affect
microbes without being exquisitely anti-microbial.
But also without
targeting a single causative pathogen.
And then, finally, in the 1970s and 80s--
as genetically modified mice were introduced--
several of them
recapitulate IBD like phenotypes with a disruptive
microbiome.
So, again, without a single organism that
could be
blamed for this disease.
And then in the past decade or so as sequencing
has become such a common tool to
better understand how the gut microbiome is
disrupted in IBD, things progressed fairly
rapidly.
From early
observations of reduced diversity or dysbiosis--
so just lacking the typical range of microbes
found in the gut--
through identifying which organisms become
more or less abundant during IBD.
To finally starting to differentiate
how these affect the main subsets of inflammatory
bowel disease.
So these include things like ulcerative colitis,
Crohn's disease.
And you'll see some more details about these
on
the next two slides.
So in terms of how these data can be analyzed,
you can, again, compare a lot about these
sort of complex disruptions in the microbiome
to complex human genetics.
So if you think about infectious disease or
Mendelian human genetic diseases, these are
both due to a single
cause of large effect.
So a genetic disorder like cystic fibrosis
really comes from a single locus, and that
causes
most of the disease effect.
From a microbial side, a parallel would be
a pathogen.
So something like color that's
really caused by a single organism of large
effect.
There's been a great deal of work on complex
human genetics in the past two decades.
And these include traits
and diseases that are caused, not by one to
locus of large effect, but by the synergistic
effect of many genes or
pathways working together.
And this seems to be the case in complex microbial
dysbiosis as well, in which there's
not a single pathogen but a functional consequence
of many bugs, or the normal ecology of the
gut or other parts
of the human microbiome becoming disrupted.
So to better understanding of disruption in
inflammatory bowel disease, during HMP2, we
worked with Ramnik
Xavier's group at [INAUDIBLE] to put together
a cohort of just over 100 individuals who
were followed for one year
each.
Consisting about half of Crohn's disease patients,
a quarter of ulcerative colitis patients,
and about a quarter
non-idd controls.
The cohort was recruited from a series of
different clinical centers, roughly half adults
and half
pediatrics.
And these very generous patients contributed
stool samples every two years-- or sorry--
every two
weeks for one year.
These were our primary sample type with which
to study the gut microbiome, in addition to
colon biopsies
collected at enrollment, and blood draws collected
roughly quarterly.
So from these three different sample types,
we are able to get a whole set of different
data.
Much of the stool derived data described the
microbiome, mainly
using sequencing, metagenomics and metatranscriptomics,
in addition to a series of other molecular
data types,
metabolomics and proteomics from mass spec--
like I mentioned earlier-- a subset of virally
targeted sequencing.
And then some of hos targeted measurements
from the stool samples, including [INAUDIBLE],
which is a protein
measure of gut inflammation.
Our biopsies and blood draws provided mostly
human focused data, some of which was, again,
sequencing.
Including exome sequencing of the human hosts,
epigenetic [INAUDIBLE] sequencing of methylation--
both right
in the gut from the biopsies and in circulating
blood.
And then a couple of other non sequencing
data types there,
including serology from the blood-- so antibody
markers in circulating blood.
And, finally, 16S or amplicon
sequencing of microbes, again, directly in
the gut from these biopsy samples.
So you can see from these numbers down the
side that there are several thousand samples
touching many
different data types describing, as mandated,
both microbial and host changes over time
during IBD.
To give an
overview of how this broke down over both
time and the individuals within the populations,
for each phenotype--
Crohn's disease, ulcerative colitis, and our
control individuals-- we had a sub-population
of it very densely
sampled.
So generating data from almost every sample
provided over the course of the year.
And then subpopulations
that were targeted to specific aligned time
points.
What this allowed us to do is generate multi
omic data to integrate as many of these different
data types as
possible over time.
So this complicated subway diagram here is
essentially a venn diagram listing the overlap
between these different data types, anchored
off of methagenomics sequencing, for which
we had a total of just
under 1,700 samples.
And most of these overlapped with one or more
other molecular data types.
So I won't go through that-- the details here,
but for example, essentially all of the methatranscriptome
sequence
data sets were drawn from the same samples
as a methagenome.
Essentially all of the methaproteinomic and
metabolomic samples were also drawn from underlying
methagenomes, and so forth, and so forth.
Down to
roughly 300 samples, for which we have all
six of these microbially targeted data types
from the same sample
time points and individuals.
So this gives us an opportunity to look at
how each measurement of the microbiome changes
over time, and how
they integrate with each other cross-sectionally
and dynamically.
So all of these data are being made available
as
they are generated.
Essentially all of them are online currently
at the IBD multiomic database or IBD MDV portal,
in addition to the main HMP Data Coordinating
Center that I mentioned earlier.
The IBD MDV has a little more
focused information for our project in particular,
including all of the protocols that we used
for sample collection
and data generation.
So if you're interested in doing your own
study and really want to collect thousands
of stool samples, there's a
protocol describing how we did that using
a home based kit that could be dropped in
the mail and shipped in.
And
then, of course, all the raw and processed
data are being made available on the IBD MDV
as well, along with the
clinical metadata describing these patients,
their medical histories, their medication,
and how these change over
the course of a year.
To show a few first looks at how we've been
integrating some of these different molecular
data types in the HM2, I'll show an example
first of work comparing the gut metagenome
to the get
metatranscriptome.
So in other words, the collection of DNA that's
present in microbes during IBD, and the
collection of RNA-- or their transcriptional
activity-- in the gut.
So this is an example from one pathway, N-acetygucosamine
degradation, which is a type of mucous metabolism
carried out by a subset of gut microbes.
Each column here represents the distribution
of which organisms or
expressing, transcriptionally, this pathway
across a subset of one of our pilot data sets
within the HMP2.
So
there's a smaller number of samples here,
obviously.
In almost every individual, bacteroides vulgatus--
this specific species that's common in the
gut-- is uniquely
responsible for this type of mucous metabolism.
And when we look at this not just cross-sectionally
but
longitudinally that's true within most subjects
over time as well.
So when we take one patient's four time points
that
we have in this pilot data set, at each time
point, bacteroides vulgatus is both the only
organism carrying this
pathway in its genome, and the only organism
transcribe-- essentially the only organism
transcribing it.
So this is
likely the bug responsible for this particular
portion of mucous metabolism in the gut for
this individual.
But that's not true for all patients.
So if we go to another individual with more
active disease, bacteroides vulgatus
is typically the dominant organism carrying
this pathway in its DNA.
But other organisms take over that
functionality at different points in time.
So even very rare organisms can become responsible
for this type of
biochemistry transiently.
So in this second time point, a different
bacteroides, the [INAUDIBLE] has taken over
[INAUDIBLE] of the pathway.
In the third time point, bacteroides massiliensis
has taken over, and so forth.
As this patient goes through more
active changes in their [INAUDIBLE] status,
the organisms carrying this pathway don't
change.
But the organism is
carrying out this activity.
The organism transcribing this particular
mucous metabolism pathway change from time
point of time point.
So this can reflect an aspect of instability
in the gut microbiome corresponding to disease
activity that's not
necessarily visible in just measuring the
DNA, but which can be seen in which bugs are
carrying out a pathway
transcriptome, This seems to be a general
principle within the gut.
Not just true in disease activity.
But even a
baseline if we compare which organisms can
contribute all pathways to which organisms
are actively transcribing
them.
So here on the y-axis each point represents
one pathway.
Just like this overall path does boiled down
to a single
point.
On the y-axis is the diversity of how many
organisms can contribute a pathway.
On the x-axis is the diversity
of how many organisms are transcribing that
pathway.
Everything is above the diagonal, which is
good.
You expect more bugs to carry pathway than
to activate it at any
given time.
Excuse me.
And what's interesting here is that in the
lower left are the more unique pathways, those
that are only carried by a few bugs.
And if you look at the coloring, this corresponds
to how actively transcribed
that pathway is.
And these tend to light up.
So the more unique a functionality is, the
more it tends to be over-expressed.
Another example of this in a
different organism is methanagenesis.
This is a pathway that's really only present
in a very few bugs, the archaea
in the gut.
And it can be over expressed by as much as
100-fold.
So those few bugs that can perform that specific
biochemistry, tend to work really hard at
it.
They're carrying out their particular function,
their particular niche in
the gut.
We can perform this type of multiomic data
comparison for other combinations of molecular
data in the
microbiome as well.
So that example compared methagenomes to methatranscriptomes
in one of our pilot data
sets.
We can do something similar comparing methagenomes
to metabolomes, or the abundances of the different
small molecules in the gut in the stool samples
from the HMP2.
So this is a slightly different pilot data
set, again, not including the stool final
sample set.
But here we've
measured-- in addition to methagenomes-- the
abundances of about 400 or 500 identified
compounds, and
several thousand unidentified compounds in
collaboration with [INAUDIBLE] group at the
Broad Institute.
So this
plot summarizes the classes and number of
each class of compounds that are individually
enriched or depleted in
Crohn's disease and ulcerative colitis, very
much like the microbial enrichments or depletions
in IBD that I
mentioned earlier.
But where things get more interesting is when
we start integrating these small molecules
chemical changes with
the microbial changes.
This plot shows the correlation of organisms
that are either enriched or depleted during
inflammatory bowel disease with small molecules,
chemicals, that are enriched in the gut or
depleted during
inflammatory bowel disease.
So each cell in the heat mass correlates a
bug with a compound.
And this is after
correcting for a variety of co-variants--
so things like subject age, antibiotic exposure,
or even disease activity
itself.
So even though these are bugs and compounds
that are disrupted in disease, we tried to
regress out as much of
that effect as we can so we can instead look
at microbial biochemical co-variation.
What this then means when a
bug-- or what it suggests when a bug in a
small molecule co-variant exists strongly
across the population, is that
there might be something mechanistic going
on.
This could be a compound that a positively
correlated organism
generates biochemically, or it could be a
compound that co-varies because of this bug
depends on it as a nutrient.
Or alternatively, an organism might ecologically
interact with another organism that generates
or depends on this
compound.
And some of these co-variations are so strong.
We find a lot of very striking correlations
between microbes and
very specific compounds.
Some of these are so strong that we can do
some gazing into the methagenomes to
help explain mechanistically why these observational
correlations might be happening.
An example of that-- we'll see an example
of that from ruminococcus gnavus, specifically
in a few slides.
But it's
surprising how often these correlations happen
for unintuitive reasons.
There's a lot of-- a theme that I'll come
back to a couple of times, that there's a
lot we don't know about microbial biochemistry
in the wild, in the gut, and
in other parts of the human microbiome.
So when we go looking for known enzymes--
annotated microbial genes that are non degenerate
or metabolize
specific compounds-- we find very few cases
in which we can correlate a known enzyme with
the compound that it
generates or consumes.
There are a few of these examples with ethanolamine
or glutatione, for example.
And
these are annotations of the enzymes responsible
for processing those compounds across the
samples, and in a
variety of different organisms.
But these are the exceptions rather than the
rule.
And if there are microbiologists in the audience
and you look
closely at this slide, you can actually guess
why this might be happening, in as much as
there's a lot of green.
So
the color here indicates which organisms are
contributing these enzymes in each of the
three genotypes, IBD,
Crohn's disease, ulcerative colitis and controls.
And if you compare the enrichments for these
organisms to the legend below, you can see
that green is actually
e.coli, which is one of the best annotated
organisms were we do know quite a bit of biochemistry,
and we can
assign biochemical function to many of its
genes.
But there are very few cases where we can
find this specific of
information so far.
So even though we can identify genes that
co-vary with compounds, they may be completely
unannotated.
So there's a lot of biochemistry left to discover
there.
We can-- just from a purely computational
or machine learning perspective-- use those
unannotated genes or
compounds to ask questions about IBD more
broadly.
So, for example, it's fairly easy to fairly
well differentiate the
IBD gut from a controlled microbiome-- so
from non IBD or quote healthy controls.
So using, in this case, a
random forest classifier-- but this is true
for essentially any descriminative of machine
learning algorithm-- we can
separate individuals with and without IBD
with fairly good accuracy using either a measurement
of which
chemicals are there, a measurement of which
bugs are there, or it's not on this plot--
we can do the same thing
using a measure of which genes are there.
The classification test gets a little bit
harder when we differentiate the sub-types
of IBD.
So, for example,
separating ulcerative colitis from Crohn's
disease drops the accuracy a little bit.
But what I think is interesting
about this result was that the machine learner
can do roughly as well whether it's learning
from chemicals or which
organisms are present in the microbiome.
Or, again, not shown here, but the same is
true for genes and pathways in the microbiome.
Which, again, points
to the very tight link between which bugs
and which biochemical DNA is present-- which
enzymes are present in
the gut-- and the metabolite pool that we
observed through your metabolic profiling
of the gut microbiome.
So, finally, to get to one more specific example
of this-- by zooming further into that ruminococcus
gnavus
example I mentioned earlier-- we have a third
pilot data set from within the HMP-- within
the HMP2-- that I'll use
for this example, which compared specifically
the dense, longer, longitudinal time forces
across Crohn's disease
and a subset of the control subjects.
So in taking a look at this longitudinal data
set, Branley Miranda, the post doc
who worked on this project did, was ask questions
about the functionality of microbes that were
changing in IBD,
or in Crohn's disease specifically over time.
And one of the things that they found that's
been suggested by metagenomic profiling earlier
is that there are
more commonalities in the types of biochemistry
that gets perturbed during IBD than in the
specific organisms.
And one example of this is the class of facilitative
anaerobes, or aero tolerant microbes in the
gut, tend to be
And one example of this is the class of facilitative
anaerobes, or aero tolerant microbes in the
gut, tend to be
enriched in IBD.
And the causality for this could go either
way.
So this could either be a function of more
oxygen being present in the gut during inflammation
and allowing these
bugs to grow.
Or these bugs being pro-inflammatory and sort
of causing the inflammation and the IBD in
the first
place.
But you can see this in enrichment for a whole
group of different organisms either when comparing
the
Crohn's and control individuals from within
this HMP2 pilot data set, or when comparing
it to other external got
microbiome data sets, including the healthy
population in the HMP1, or another Crohn's
disease study carried out
at University of Pennsylvania.
Individual organisms may not show such a strong
enrichment during inflammation.
But the entire class of aero
tolerant organisms does.
And you can see this when we zoom into ruminococcus
gnavus as a representative of
this group of organisms.
It's weakly enriched individually, but the
overall functional enrichment is a lot more
statistically significant.
What's interesting about ruminococcus gnavus
though, is that one of the reasons it's so
hard to see this
enrichment in an individual organism is that
it's not the whole organism that seems to
be associated with
inflammatory bowel disease and inflammation
of the microbiome.
It's only certain strains of ruminococcus
gnavus.
So what you're looking at here is on each
column, is a one sample from either a Crohn's
disease or control
individual who did carry ruminococcus gnavus
in their gut.
And you can see there's a small number of
control
individuals for carrying ruminococcus gnavus.
But there are about 200 genes-- and that what
each row represents-- that were only carried
by the strains of
microbes-- that strains-- of ruminococcus
gnavus present in the IBD gut.
And we can put biochemical annotations
on a small set of these genes.
Some of them deal with aero tolerance and
oxidative stress management.
Others
correspond to more pathogen or pathobiont-like
functions like adhesion or invasion.
And others have really
interesting metabolic annotations like iron
utilization.
But the vast majority are, again, unannotates.
They don't have good homology to other well-characterized
enzymes out in reference databases.
So in as much as I'll, again, come back to
this a few times, it's a
microbiological or biochemical challenge to
figure out what these genes do.
But I as a computational biologist, I
would also frame it as a data management challenge.
So a lot of low hanging fruit in using slightly
more intelligent
algorithms than just plain homology to start
getting an idea of what some of this microbial
dark matter that seems
functionally significant in the microbiome
might be doing.
So with that in mind, I'll spend some of the
rest of the time on what you can think of
as the other HMP2, or a
second wave of analysis carried out in the
quote healthy or baseline population of the
HMP1.
So to help
differentiate this population, I'll refer
to examples from this study as the HMP1-II.
so this is a set of similarly
flavored analyzes carried out on methagenomes
from the HMP1 healthy population.
And so I introduced this briefly earlier--
but to go into a little bit more detail of
how the HMP1 defined a baseline
microbiome-- this population included 300
quote healthy subjects who were screened at
five different body areas
for a fairly high and specific degree of clinical
health.
So very few oral health or oral hygiene issues.
There was a
specific BMI range that had to be followed.
No skin abrasions, for example.
And this allowed up to 18 different bodies
sites to be sampled.
Not just the gut, but a series of nasal.
Many
different oral sites across the mouth.
A few different skin sites.
Again, stool representing the gut, and a series
of
different vaginal microbiome samples in women.
The HMP1 and 1-II included three different
visits to get a little bit of longitudinal
information for this population as
well.
And as well as, again, metadata describing
the demographics and background and environment
of these
individuals.
So the initial sets of information published
with the HMP1 several years ago focused mainly
on the
several amplicon samples that were analyzed
across essentially all of these samples that
were collected.
For the HMP1-II, more recently we just finished
analysis of about 2,400 methagenomes across
a subset of these
individual and body sites, but now spanning
roughly all three time points for all individuals,
and a subset of six
representative body sites from the different
areas.
So we'll talk about some of the results from
that.
I think some of
the interesting data challenges here was certainly
wrangling this large a set of methagenomes,
performing things
like quality control, raw bioinformatics on
the methagenomic sequencing data.
And methagenomic assembly was
greatly facilitated by, again, Owen White's
team at the Data Coordinating Center, who
are doing this as part of the
NIH Data Commons Project, in addition to the
HMP2.
What we could then get out of that is not
just more data than we had in the HMP1, but
a series of updated
analyzes, including very specific functional
profiling-- that we'll see in a few slides.
Very specific taxonomic
profiling-- down to the tracking of individual
strains.
And we'll describe some of the computing behind
that as well.
And then a few things I won't have time for
today, including non-bacterial profiling--
fungi and viruses-- the
updated assembly that I mentioned, gene catalogues
that derived from these assemblies, and then
a little bit
about the multiple time point dynamics that
I will describe the analysis methods for.
But to start with some of the easy views of
what this information can tell you, to start
at a 30,000 foot view of the
overall human microbiome.
These methagenomic profiles now show much
the same information that was
available from the amplicon data originally
in the HMP1, in which many of the largest
differences in the human
microbiome across the body are derived from
the body site itself.
Bug care about their immediate biochemical
environments.
Microbes are essentially little bags of biochemistry.
So when you ask, well, what are the biggest
differences across the human microbiome, the
first answer is the
immediate environment, the body site that
a collection of microbes likes to live in.
So that means when we put
these 2,400 metagenomes together, most of
the variation that we can see at a high level
derives from the
different body sites from which those samples
are derived.
The gut is a very unique environment that
tends to
carry out a different microbial ecology.
The same is true for skin.
The vaginal microbiome sights were quite similar
to each other, but distinct from the
other microbial environment samples here.
And then I mentioned there were multiple different
oral body sites,
which you can see here in the kind of cool
colors, and a continuum in which we can actually--
I'll shows some
examples later-- differentiate fairly specific
locations within the oral cavity, such as
the tooth surface, the cheek, or
the tongue, which were the three main oral
sights studied here.
This is a very high level view, in which each
point represents a sample, and the distance
between points
represents how dissimilar they are.
But, of, course this is supported by very
detailed information underneath--
both per sample listing which organisms are
there and their abundances-- and as we'll
see in a few slides,
differentiating those organisms into specific
strains as well.
The first analysis I want to described using
the information about these taxonomic profiles
though, was in
characterizing how they changed over time.
This is something new within the HMP1-II,
and uses what I think was
an interesting data analysis method for this
type of data, specifically Gaussian processes.
So you can think of a
Gaussian process as a probabilistic functional
regression.
So a way of fitting a curve probabilistically
to a series of
measurements over time.
Which is exactly what we have here.
We have a series of multiple time points measured
for the microbiome, each
measuring a collection of organisms in different
individuals, and in different 46 body sets.
So we wanted to ask how different organisms
were changing over time across the body within
the microbiome.
And Gaussian processes gave us a way to do
that by decomposing each of these set of changes
into a couple of
specific mechanisms.
So specifically, we built a set of Gaussian
processes to model microbial change as a
combination of stable inter-individual differences.
So bugs that are just all the difference between
people, and their
abundances depend on who you are, not what
time it is.
Microbes that very steadily over time.
And these are organisms that might, for example,
be responsive to long
term dietary perturbations, or long term medical
pharmaceutical interventions.
So things like antibiotics.
And then, finally, since we had a series of
technical replicators, we could to differentiate
between microbes that
change rapidly on their own biologically versus
those that have measurement error and have
essentially technical
noise.
So you can think of this as rapid change,
and this as a measurement error.
So by fitting probabilistic this
hierarchical Gaussian process to our longitudinal
data, we can describe each bug in terms of
these three
properties of interest.
So this differs ably between individuals.
Does it change slowly over time, or does it
change rapidly over time?
So these three locations in the plot I'm about
to show correspond to these three temporal
patterns.
State-- the stability between individuals,
slow temporal
change, and rapid temporal change.
And we can then plot over this complex each
organism.
Or it turns out-- and I won't show it today--
you can do the
same thing for pathways within a particular
body site.
So it's here we've broken down the gut microbiome
in that
healthy population of the HMP1-II based on
these temporal behaviors.
And you can immediately see some
consistency in what the different microbes
are doing.
The bacteroides, which are one of the dominant
groups of bugs in the gut, tend to be stable
within individuals over
time.
Some people will have one bacteroides, and
some people have a different type of bacteroides.
These blue dots represent another major group
of organisms in the gut, the fermicutes.
They tend overall to show
more slow variation.
So this might include things like diet responsiveness.
And then, finally, a subset of more opportunistic
organisms like e.coli change rapidly over
time.
They can grow or
die off or grow again very quickly in response
to a changing environment.
So zooming in to a slightly higher level
of taxonomic information, we can profile not
just which organisms are present in the gut
microbiome, but which
strains of each organism are present.
And one-- a quick one slide summary of one
of the computational methods for doing this
relies on mapping the
short reads within a metagenome to a collection
of pre-specified unique marker sequences for
each species.
So
for this particular tool called StrainPhlAn,
we take a collection of reference sequence
information.
We identify the
most unique sequences for each species.
And then given a new method genome, we can
map those short reads
to just these unique markers and cull snippet
variants within those constantly identified
markers.
This allows for each species and each sample
the construction of a strain level haplotype,
a set of variants unique
to the strain of that species in each sample.
And these can then be visualized in a number
of different ways, some
of which are exactly the same as you would
do for microbial genetics in a collection
of isolates by looking at the
phylogeny, or divergence, between strains
in different samples.
You can associate these with phenotype.
So for example, this is the phylogeny of the
strains of one organism across many different
gut microbiomes, this
set of strains is enriched for the cartoon
red phenotype, and this set of strains is
enriched for the purple
phenotype.
Equivalently, you can show the same type of
information, again, in an ordination like
we saw earlier.
But here each point represents the strain
of a particular species in one metagenome.
And distance between
points represents how diverged, genetically,
those strains are.
So using that, we can both associate strains
with phenotypes, like I showed in the previous
slide, or ask some
basic biological questions about how strains
evolve in the human microbiome in the first
place.
So one of the ways
in which we did this was by comparing the
genetic diversity of organisms within each
body site to the diversity
between body sites.
Some organisms like to specialize to a particular
biochemical environment, and essentially
diverge into different organisms across body
sites.
Whereas other organisms transfer genetic material
more
freely, and are more cosmopolitan.
And you can see this better with some examples.
Where if I take a point that's right on this
diagonal, the diversity
of strep salivarius.
Between and within body sites is roughly the
same.
So each point here represents one strain of
strep salivarius from a number of different
body sites.
You can see there's a great deal of genetic
diversity, but it doesn't really segregate
within any particular part of the
oral cavity.
And so this is a typically oral microbe.
A counterexample is something like haemophilus
parainfluenzae, which is off the diagonal
here.
This organism has a comparable amount of genetic
diversity, but
it's started to differentiate into groups
of strains that are unique to each of the
three main oral sites.
So you can
actually find different types of h.parainfluenze
on the tooth surface, versus the cheek, versus
the tongue.
This is the level of biochemical specialization
that some microbes in the microbiome are able
to attain.
And you
can actually differentiate different ecological
strategies genetically across very, very nearby
surfaces within the
oral cavity.
So, finally, I'll wrap up now we have methods
for detecting who is there in the microbiome,
but with a little bit about
functional profiling and understanding the
biochemistry that we can detect from metagenomes
and
metatranscriptomes.
So a quick one slide summary of one of the
methods we have to do that starts with, again,
a
metagenome or metatranscriptome.
And after detecting which organisms are present
in the sample using the
methods they described earlier, retrieve their
reference sequences from an underlying database.
So not just the unique markers or the most
specific sequences, but all genes or the pan-genome
associated with
each organism in a community.
Maps, metagenomic or metatranscriptomic reads
to those genes, count up hits,
and can thereby describe which genes and which
organisms are carrying them in a community.
And then, finally,
for reasons that do not map to specific nucleotides,
we carry out a more computationally expensive
translated
search.
Hits from this process to a larger protein
database can still tell you something about
the biochemistry of
what that gene might be doing, but not necessarily
which organism is churning it.
So this gives a functional profile of a microbial
community in which we can quantify-- very
much like you would for
say a transfer [INAUDIBLE] or RNA seek-- the
abundance of each gene family in the community
in units that are
basically like RPKMS or relative abundances.
And these are broken down, when possible,
into the contributing
organism for each gene family, or into a set
of unclassified organisms when we only know
that the protein level if
the gene family is there.
For the subset of these gene families that
are biochemically characterized, we can also
put them back together into pathways and do
the same thing to quantify and taxonomically
annotate the
contributions of each pathway to a community,
in addition to the uncharacterized gene families.
So I'm running a little low on time.
I'll move quickly through the last few examples
of using this within the human
microbiome, including things like finding
human specific pathways, so pathways that
are carried microbially across
many different biochemical environments on
the body.
And these speak to processes these that are
enriched in
host associated microbes.
So things that bugs have to do somewhere in
their ecology in order to survive in
association with a human being.
And you can see from this one example of vitamin
D metabolism on the bottom here, that across
the body many
different organisms might carry out this process.
But it seems to be necessary for it to be
carried out by some
organism within the community to form a stable
ecology.
And this is in addition, of course, to body
site or
biochemically specific processes that are
carried out by different bugs within a specific
environment.
So, for, example nitrate reduction is always
carried out by some organism in the oral cavity.
But this can, again, be
a different organism from person to person
or mouth to mouth, in this case.
So this type of functional profiling
gives us sort of a way of linking ecology
and biochemistry in the microbiome by looking
at the diversity of
organisms that can provide a pathway, both
within an individual or between individuals.
Ranging from pathways that are more or less
core to the human microbiome-- they must be
present in every
individual in some environments.
Sometimes, rarely, these are provided by a
specific organism.
And that organism
is the same between individuals.
But more commonly, there's diversity in which
organisms can provide a particular
type of biochemistry.
So here's an example in which only one organism
per individual tends to provide a pathway,
but that organism
can differ between individuals.
And then, finally, more typically there can
be many different microbes per individual
that can carry out a particular type of biochemistry,
and often it's not even the same bugs per
individual.
So there
can be diversity both in which organisms per
individual provide a pathway, and in how they
change between
individuals.
So this leads us to some of the challenges
in the microbial community and human microbiome
analysis and data
science, which range all the way from the
very molecular focus that I was just describing
up to higher level
questions of population health and microbial
interaction.
I highlighted already a lot of the dark matter
or open
questions around the underlying biochemistry
or cellular biology that we can see in the
microbiome from these
different types of molecular data.
And, of course, many of these affect translation
in human health.
As I mentioned in the beginning, the microbiome
provides not just a high dimensional read
out of human health,
but also a potential point of intervention.
Once we know the right direction in which
to push it, we can make
changes to a microbial community in a way
that it would be very difficult with human
genetics And, finally, many of
these human considerations have effects at
the population level as well.
So, for example, early life anti-microbial
or probiotic exposures might then influence
microbiome acquisition or development, and
thus later life allergic or
atopic phenotypes as well.
So all the tools that I briefly mentioned
today are available online as part of the
labs bioBakery collection, both of
individual open source methods, and a virtual
image that includes all of these pre-built
and documented and set
up within a single environment.
So if you're interested in follow up work
using any of these methods, take a look at
the bioBakery site.
And I'd like to thank all of those faces that
you saw going by who are the people who actually
did the work, either in the lab-- or several
of our collaborators much of his work was
with Ramnik Xavier, at the
Broad.
I mentioned Owen and [INAUDIBLE], group at
the University of Maryland.
Wendy Garrett here at School of Public
Health.
And then several former lab members such as
Nicholas [INAUDIBLE], who have since gone
on to carry on
a great deal of this work on their own.
So with that, I'll wrap up.
Again, thanks to the organizers, the audience.
And
I think there is a little time left for questions.
Curtis, this was a fantastic talk.
Thank you so much for sharing this with us.
This is really-- I've got about 4,000
questions, and in five minutes to ask them
in.
But I want to-- just these are some questions
of my own.
And as
somebody who's not a microbiomisist, this
is fascinating for me.
And when I-- back in the olden days when I
was learning about genetics, there was a real
emphasis-- at least kind
of during the initial phases of the microbiological
genomics kind of explosion-- there was still
a lot of interest in
doing population genetics, and looking at
things like gene fitness and as genes propagate
through a distribution
and whatnot.
Is there any sort of, in your opinion, opportunities
for those old school population geneticist
mathematicians to take a look at some of these
data and look at gene frequencies in some
of these different
populations, and what happens to those genes
as they spread through populations and either
are beneficial or
otherwise?
Does that make sense?
That makes sense.
It's a great question and very timely.
One of the things that I think has been exciting
about the
past years worth of computational biology
in the microbiome is the ability to see that
kind of data at sufficient
resolution to do sort of classical microbial
genetics in a culture independent or metagenomic
way.
So some of
these strain identification methods, for example,
have only just recently become precise enough
to track strain
variation and divergence in population genetics
for every bug in a community at the same time.
And we're starting
to get to the ten thousands of gut microbiome
samples available globally to do that sort
of tracking across multiple
populations simultaneously.
So I think--
Yeah, I think that is-- yeah, that is so--
it's so exciting.
Because, you know, when you're talking about
population
genetics at least, you know, the Cavalli-Sforza
and Bodmer type of old school population genetics,
you know, that
was all like very theoretical, right?
Lots of differential equations to try to theoretically
analyze what would happen if
a gene spread through a population to fixation
and Hady-Weinberg equilibrium's and so forth
and so on.
You
actually have the population of bugs to analyze
and watch what happens as a new gene gets
introduced into that
population and what happens to it.
And be able to watch the behavior of the bugs,
watch their biochemical output
as a consequence of as these genes spread
through that population what happens to them.
And is that beneficial
or not?
And I was also thinking about something you
had mentioned about the specificity of the
different bugs for their
various niches on the body.
Where you have, say, something that lives
on the skin is not necessarily the same
population of bugs which live inside the gut.
And I was also curious about-- because it
looked like you were sort of
talking about-- I don't know if you touched
on it in, particular but immune responses
to when, say, something that's
even from an individual.
Something like bugs from their gut get introduced
accidentally into a different area of the
body.
So I was thinking in my head, like, what happens
when-- because for those of us who've had
kids-- what happens
when bugs from the gut get introduced into
the eye.
This is basically pinkeye, right?
So you basically get gut bugs
introduced into the conjunctiva of the eye,
and you get an immune response of swelling
and pus and all sorts of
other nastiness.
And there's a really dramatic and obvious
immune response.
Can you imagine being able to look
at the role of the immune system in all of
this?
Definitely.
It's much more I should say Wendy's area of
expertise than mine.
But we work with her and Ramnik on
immune interactions quite a bit.
In the gut-- the kind of example that you
raised comes up in the context of gut
barrier leakiness, and the degree to which,
again, in a sort of cyclical way post triggered
inflammation can allow
microbial penetration through the gut.
And then conversely, microbial invasion can
trigger inflammation and
sustain that leakiness.
So that certainly is a factor in inflammatory
bowel disease.
Systemically there is interest.
And we've worked with
folks like Dan Libman on rheumatoid arthritis.
Where certainly either leakiness or perturbation
in the gut or
potentially circulation or triggers from distal
microbes-- like oral microbes-- could play
a factor in sort of mistriggering
the immune system systemically, and then having
it target things like the synovium at the
joints in
rheumatoid arthritis.
That's really fascinating.
And one final question is, can you give us
a comment on microbial transplantation, and
what sort of horizons exist for that?
Well, it's a great question.
And, you know, every everyone likes to talk
about foot transplants at the end of the talk.
Exactly.
So there's-- I would certainly put that pico
microbiome transplants in-- one of the real
translational success stories
of that-- the microbiome so far-- certainly
for Clostridium difficile there's been a lot
of great results in properly
screened and clinically controlled transplants
being able to really ameliorate recurrent
c-diff.
And there's starting to
be more work in FMTs for inflammatory bowel
disease, where the ecology is harder to restore.
Again, we don't
necessarily know yet what the right push is
to get the community to get it back to stability
within an individual.
And
there's a lot of subjective subject variation.
So I think some of the neatest work going
on in that space right now is in understanding,
one, what is the best
push to give to, say, an ulcerative colitis
individual?
What's the right group of microbes?
Whether that should
come from an FMT, or whether you can make
an artificial cocktail that behaves like an
FMT.
And then, two, how to tailor that to each
individual.
So that no matter what their sort of current
or baseline
microbiome is, that push gets them back to
a healthy state.
And where things like, again, strain tracking
and
understanding the biochemistry or functional
profile of what these bugs should be doing
is helpful.
Well, with that I'd like to thank Curtis Huttenhower
from Harvard Medical School-- or School of
Public Health--
excuse me-- for his fantastic talk.
I'm just so just blown away.
I have still another several thousand questions,
but
we've run out of time.
But thank you, Curtis.
That was really fantastic.
And thanks to everyone who joined us today.
For those who have
been asking, this is being recorded, and will
be available online here a little later today.
So if you want to re-watch
it or share it with friends, please, by all
means do.
And, once again, let me thank you for tuning
into the Big Data to Knowledge Guide to the
Fundamentals of Data
Science.
Please look forward to future lectures that
we'll be having here in the coming weeks.
Thanks, again.
Have a great weekend everybody.